welcome to Table Talk where I unpack
ideas and insights from Christian
theology and spirituality that help you
become a more thoughtful calm and
wonderful human being my name's Brett so
for a pastor at the table and Sachse
Texas and this is part five of our
series on relational conflict what to do
when relationships meltdown and today I
want to give you basically more thoughts
about an idea crystallized by family
therapist Edwin Friedman known as
relational triangles so in my video a
few days ago
I've talked all about relational
triangles and basically just a short
little summary they are the tendency
that everyone has when they're in
conflict to rope in a third person right
for example Susie gets offended by Jim
she doesn't talk to Jim because he know
that's difficult and uncomfortable and
instead she goes to Rachel alright so in
my video today I want to really focus in
on how to detrital that is how to get
out of a relational triangle that you
find yourself roped into that way you no
longer have to carry the stress for a
relationship you're actually powerless
to solve but before we get there let me
give you a little little footnote a
little freebie let me mention that a
relational triangle is not always
between three people but it can really
be between sometimes two people in a
third thing often an addiction so for
example Susie gets into a fight with Jim
and she's hurting but it's hard to go to
Jim she doesn't really want to deal with
that and because it's you know
uncomfortable depressing and so what is
Susie do she goes out and gets wasted
her binge watches Netflix for three days
or eats her feelings right and this is
why my beloved professor Frank Greene he
said all addiction is avoidance right in
other words it's a triangle there is
myself there are the uncomfortable
feelings right I have about that person
that situation that past pain and
emotional trauma or whatever and then I
run to the third thing whether it's
enough they
all affairs are triangles right or a
Krispy Kreme Doughnuts whatever it is to
choose go with the Krispy Kremes nope
okay right but I run to the third okay
so what do you do when you find yourself
as the third right two people are
fighting and they're like they come to
you you're caught in between them what
do you do when you find yourself being
triangle because it's painful right as
the ancient Swahili proverb says when
elephants fight it's the grass that gets
crushed so how do you stop from getting
crushed I want to give you three steps
today number one focus on yourself right
do you find yourself are you worked up
are you all agree you've got to chill
the heck out calm down
alright this little counterintuitive
because we wanted to focus on others
like go right to them and tell them
what's what and you know whatever but no
whoa slow down slow that rope if you
aren't calm you're only contributing to
the anxiety in the relational system all
right so so do what you got to do pray
go for a walk get nature call a support
group you know and attend your sport
give like whatever you do you've got to
calm down and stop obsessing over them
and all their problems right and tune in
a little bit to yourself and then
actually this is the best way you can
help them is by being non-anxious
yourself right so don't freak out you
don't go to them and scream how dare you
triangle me stop bad calm down that's
first to focus on yourself
second go ahead and now's the time to go
to them and redirect them right so
simply explain that they need to talk
with the person they have the problem
with right this seems super
straightforward and kind of obvious but
it's amazing how blind a we can be like
not realizing what's happening or be
they are often blind right about the
fact that they're coming to you to talk
about others they don't know what
they're doing but they're doing it so
simply explain to them what they're
doing and then redirect them back to one
another right so hey Susie I think it'd
be great if you went had a conversation
with Jim about that since your problems
with Jim Friedman Edwin Friedman he
tells a story about a couples therapy
session between a husband and a wife and
this is a real story and he's counseling
with them and the husband had to step
out of the session for a moment maybe
use the restroom or something so he
steps out and the wife immediately turns
to Friedman in a sort of you know
between you and me tone she kind of says
under her breath I think he might be gay
and he asked her why and she a few
reasons and then suddenly the husband
returned to the room and Fredman a
Fredman Friedman turns to the husband
and says I'm glad you're back your wife
was just telling me that she thinks you
might be gay I think he just you can see
Friedman was sort of radically untried
laying in that moment right and by the
way they went on to have a very
straightforward and productive session
now obviously that's the unique
situation and but it does show that it's
need be I mean you can be pretty bold in
your d triangle Ain
however I'd suggest as a more general
maybe a better rule of thumb instead of
that kind of radical D triangle II um
try something I call it the 48-hour rule
which is basically when song comes to
you with a problem that actually has to
do with someone else right so they're
complaining to you about so-and-so
explain to them that they have 48 hours
to tell them or else you'll go ahead and
let that person know again that's a
pretty easy way to de triangulo
while still giving them the opportunity
to be the courageous one but you will
have to have wisdom discernment to know
you know when that would make sense
in other words like when it's a really
big deal use the the 48-hour rule you
know what it's not such a big deal you
might give them more time or you might
not insist at all all right it's sort of
like that's your issue go to them and
it's enough that you just redirected
them it's not your responsibility to
like follow them but again like when you
really care about these two people it's
probably a good idea like the 48-hour
rule like hey Jim Susie I care about you
both so Susie you've got to talk to Jim
or else I'm going to you got 48 hours
the clock is ticking
all right that's intense but again
insists they have the conversation when
you really care about them all right
number three be present but not
triangles now this is you know nuanced a
little bit but they say if you want to
help bring change right if you don't if
you don't care and I don't say it in a
bad way like you don't care about them
but maybe it's just relationships you're
not high on the priority list it's not
your responsibility but if you really do
care about these people then here's what
you do you want to bring change you got
to maintain a well-defined present but
non trying old relationship with the two
people in other words you're there for
them you love them you can even listen
to them but when the conversation is no
longer a about them and what they need
to own and work through or be then
perhaps processing about the other so
that they can then have a productive
like a productive conversation with that
person write it once the converse a once
it's not one of those two things then
you simply refuse that conversation
right so that doesn't mean you have to
cut them off it doesn't mean you don't
answer their calls it just means you
aren't willing to play the triangle game
with them
and by the way this last point right
again it's not required of you I mean
the situation may be a so toxic or be
you're just not close enough to them
that you're just like I don't want any
part of this that's okay too right um
but it is a good strategy when you
really care about the two people and
their relationship with one another so
okay that's the three steps focus on
yourself redirect them be present but
not triangles well that is all for today
if you like this video please click the
like button comment subscribe and share
it with a friend
Greece in peace